the two-way frequency table below shows
data on type of vehicle driven so this
is type of vehicle driven and whether
there was an accident in the last year
so whether there was an accident in the
last year for customers of all american
auto insurance
complete the following two-way table of
column relative frequencies so that's
what they're talking here this is a
two-way table of column relative
frequencies if necessary we round your
answers to the nearest hundred so let's
see what they're saying they're saying
let's see of the accidents within the
last year 28 were where the people were
driving an suv a sport utility vehicle
and 35 were in a sports car of the no
accidents in the last year 97 were an
suv and 104 were a sports car or another
way you could think of it of the sport
utility vehicles that were driven and
the total let's see it's 28 plus 97
which is going to be
125 of that 125 28 had an accident
within the last year and 97 did not have
an accident last year similarly you
could say of the 139
sports cars
35 had an accident last year 104 did not
have an accident last year and so what
they want us to do is put those relative
frequencies in here so the way we could
think about it one right over here this
represents all of the sport utility
vehicles so one way you could think
about it that's that represents the
whole universe of the sport
the sport utility vehicles at least that
the universe that this table shows so
that's really representative of the 28
plus 97. and so in each of these we want
to put the relative frequency so this
right over here is going to be 28
28 divided by the total notice over here
is 28 but we want the we want this
number to be the fraction of the total
well the fraction of the it's going the
the fraction of the total is going to be
28 over
97 plus 28
which of course is going to be 125.
actually let me just write them all like
that first this one right over here is
going to be 97
over 125
and of course when you add this one and
this one it should add up to 1.
likewise this one's going to be 35 over
139 35 plus 104 so so 139
and this is going to be 104 over 104
plus 35 which is 139
and so let me just calculate each of
them using this calculator so let me
scroll down a little bit
and so if i do 28
divided by 125
i get
0.224 they said round your answers to
the nearest hundredth so this is 0.8
no accident within the last year 97
divided by 125. so 97
divided by 125
is equal to let's see um here if i round
to the nearest hundredth i'm going to
round up
0.78
so this is 0.78
then 35 divided by 139 35
divided by 138
is equal to round to the near 100th 0.25
0.25
and then 104 divided by 139
divided by
it gets me
if i round to the nearest 100 0.75
0.75
and i can check my answer and i got it
right but the key thing here is to make
sure we understand what's going on here
so we could one way to think about this
is 22 of the sport utility vehicles had
an accident within the last year or you
could say 20 or you could say 0.22 of
them and you could say 78 percent or
0.78 of the sports you uh of the
of the sport utility vehicles had no
accidents likewise you could say 25 of
the sports cars had an accident in the
last year and 75 did not have a 75 did
not have an accident in the last year so
it allows you to think more in terms of
the relative frequencies the whole the
percentages however you want to think
about it well this gives you the actual
numbers